dans le reste de l'actualité cette étude
indépendante douze ans après la
catastrophe de tchernobyl qui indique
pour la première fois une contamination
radioactive de l'ensemble du massif des
alpes aujourd'hui encore cette
radioactivité dont on avait nié
l'existence est toujours présente le
détail de l'enquète didier guyot et jean
bernard schmidt l'hiver 97 dans le
massif du mercantour appareils de mesure
en 1 les chercheurs de la criirad
inspectent le terrain et une
constatation s'impose elle ici comme
d'ailleurs dans l'ensemble des alpes en
france suisse italie en autriche
les taux de radioactivité sont élevés
beaucoup plus qu'en plein 2,50 à 5 145
1000 becquerels ou kg à certains
endroits la pluie a fait descendre les
radionucléides jusqu'au sol et en plus
certaines parties du nuage ont vraiment
baigner la végétation imprégné la
végétation et produit ainsi un dépôt
même sexe est à dire un défaut
instantanée immédiat douze ans après
tchernobyl la radioactivité la fixés
dans le sol des massifs des dizaines
d'échantillons et examiner face à de
telles conclusions les chercheurs
demandent que des études approfondies
soient enfin mené par les états
concernés afin de délimiter les zones à
risque et de prévenir la population
l'ampleur de ce travail fait que nous ne
nous pouvons pas le faire tout seul
qu'il faudra des partenaires il faudra
que des volontés politiques pour que ce
travail d'investigation que nous avons
fait qu'amorcer puisse se continuer et
nous permet de pouvoir dé limiter de
manière
très fine les zones contaminées ensuite
informer les populations évidemment par
un balisage de ces zones les autorités
officielles et les défenseurs du
nucléaire ne conteste pas les traces de
radioactivité décelé dans les alpes mais
il estime tout de même que le rapport de
la criirad est beaucoup trop alarmiste
il n'y a aucun danger pour les
populations qui vivent dans ces régions
mais pour les produits venant de ces
régions qui peuvent être consommés rieur
et encore moins pour les touristes qui
fréquentent ces régions les alertes est
tout à fait hors de proportion avec les
taux calculé de radioactivité résiduelle
sur ses tâches en mai 86 le gouvernement
annonçait que le territoire français
avait été totalement épargné dans le
nuage de tchernobyl
douze ans après les chiffres démontrent
que la radioactivité est toujours bel et
bien la liste race son faible mais elle
existe